-Marine Calmet,
comment vous définiriez-vous ?
Avocate ?
Militante ? Guerrière ?
Gardienne de la nature ?
-Un peu tout ça, en vérité.
J'ai adopté le terme de gardienne,
parce qu'il renvoie à la fois
à une certaine forme de poésie
et, en même temps,
à un rôle très sérieux :
celui de se dépasser soi-même
en tant qu'humain
et endosser cette responsabilité
de représenter plus
que les simples humains,
aussi la nature,
les écosystèmes
dans lesquels nous vivons
et dont nous avons
la responsabilité.
-Vous êtes jeune, mais vous comptez
déjà de beaux combats.
Le projet minier Montagne d'or,
soutenu en son temps en Guyane
par Emmanuel Macron,
l'EPR de Flamanville, aussi.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a amené
à vous intéresser à ces sujets ?
-Leur dimension.
Elles sont le symbole
d'une société qui va mal,
qui surexploite la nature,
qui transforme les paysages,
qui détruit le monde dans lequel
on est pourtant implanté.
Cette dimension pharaonique
est le symbole d'une société malade
qui vit dans l'outrance
et dans l'irrespect du vivant.
-Dans le cas de Flamanville,
un arrêté du ministère de l'Ecologie
a permis à la centrale de continuer
à fonctionner
alors même qu'elle avait été jugée
non conforme
en raison
de failles sécuritaires.
Des aberrations comme celle-ci,
vous y êtes souvent confrontée ?
-Oui. Le droit nucléaire,
c'est un droit exorbitant,
c'est un droit
qui est tellement lié
aux intérêts politiques
qu'en fait,
on le transforme,
on le façonne,
parfois en délaissant
des choses aussi simples
que la sécurité la plus essentielle
de nos populations
ou des considérations écologiques.
Sous prétexte de sauver
les intérêts économiques,
on va faciliter
des dérogations qui sont
irresponsables.
-Comment se fait-il qu'aujourd'hui,
une entreprise a plus de droits
que la nature ?
Ca devrait être le contraire,
a priori.
On devrait donner des droits
à la nature et pas à ceux
qui l'abîment.
-Justement, oui.
La nature n'a aucun droit
dans notre société,
ce qui n'est pas vrai
pour toutes.
Il y a énormément de sociétés,
historiquement,
qui protégeaient en priorité
les communs
et qui, justement,
mettaient de côté ou, je dirais,
canalisaient les intérêts
ou les pulsions individuelles.
-Prédatrices ?
-Exactement.
C'est un mouvement historique
assez récent,
au regard de l'humanité
et même du monde occidental.
Là où, traditionnellement,
on protégeait les communs,
progressivement,
avec la création même
de la personne morale,
qui est un ovni juridique,
qui a encore
quelques centaines d'années,
la personne morale
devient de plus en plus puissante
au fur et à mesure
que son capital augmente.
Quand vous avez des sociétés
qui pèsent aussi lourd
que des Etats,
ça déséquilibre ce rapport de force.
Ces personnes qui représentent
un intérêt privé
se retrouvent à chuchoter
à l'oreille de ceux qui font la loi.
C'est comme ça
qu'une personne morale
peut avoir le respect
de son image,
le respect de sa propriété
au détriment de tous les autres.
On pense à de nombreux
procès environnementaux
qui l'ont illustré,
et notamment, par exemple,
Texaco Chevron, en Equateur,
où des pollutions monumentales
ont conduit
à énormément de morts, de malades,
une forêt décimée
sur de très nombreuses décennies,
et une multinationale
qui se cache derrière le droit
pour, justement, s'en tirer,
pour ne jamais payer.
-Où en est-on, de ce procès
Texaco Chevron en Equateur ?
L'Equateur a inscrit les droits
de sa terre, la terre-mère,
dans sa constitution.
-Oui. Ca avait amené
à une condamnation en Equateur,
mis Texaco Chevron a réussi
à casser ce jugement en se cachant
derrière le droit international
et reste aujourd'hui
parfaitement impuni.
C'est le cas dans de nombreux
endroits dans le monde.
Ce qui est fondamental
à retenir de l'histoire,
c'est que, justement,
le peuple d'Equateur,
traumatisé par cette histoire
extrêmement lourde,
a saisi l'occasion de réviser
sa constitution et a intégré
en 2008
les droits de la terre-mère
dans l'article 71
de sa constitution,
pour dire "plus jamais ça".
-L'Equateur a révisé
sa constitution,
mais ça n'a aucun impact
juridique concret
sur Texaco Chevron,
sur cette affaire en particulier.
-Justement
car le droit international
est régi par tout un tas
de considérations libérales,
et surtout parce que, du coup,
Texaco Chevron se cache,
notamment derrière
les tribunaux d'arbitrage,
cette justice privée
qui, justement,
lui permet
d'échapper à la justice nationale,
celle de l'Equateur,
alors que d'autres
sociétés minières
souhaitant s'implanter en Equateur
sont confrontées à cette justice.
On a eu de belles victoires.
L'année dernière,
Dans la forêt de Los Cedros,
le juge a annulé les permis miniers
délivrés aux entreprises
à la demande des citoyens,
à la demande des collectivités,
et a donné l'opportunité
à l'Etat de l'Equateur
de réécrire un plan de gestion
intégrant particulièrement
la question de la protection
des droits de la nature,
comme un présupposé
à la bonne gestion de ce territoire.
-On va parler des failles juridiques
et du droit
en matière d'environnement.
Je voudrais revenir à vous.
Vous avez fréquenté,
Marine Calmet,
les grands cabinets d'avocats,
mais également
les chemins de traverse,
notamment ceux
de Notre-Dame-des-Landes.
Qu'êtes-vous allée chercher là-bas,
et qu'en avez-vous retiré ?
-Je me suis toujours intéressée
à ces luttes de terrain,
parce qu'elles nous montrent aussi
la diversité des moyens d'action,
cette richesse
qu'on retrouve dans les territoires,
qui ne fait pas que contester,
qui protège aussi
un certain idéal, un idéal
dans lequel, justement,
les êtres humains vivent
en harmonie avec leurs terres,
ne sont pas dans cette relation
de prédation,
de violation de la nature,
mais se voient comme des gardiens
et des gardiennes de leur territoire
et disent :
"Ce projet
est fondamentalement incompatible
"avec le futur que je souhaite
laisser à mes enfants."
C'était aussi les luttes
de Notre-Dame-des-Landes.
Tous ces grands projets illustrent
fondamentalement la rupture
avec le monde
de ceux qui se projettent
comme étant les propriétaires
de cette planète,
ceux qui peuvent exploiter
à outrance la Terre
et tous les éléments
de la nature
et les autres, qui se voient
comme parties prenantes,
comme membres inséparables
de cette communauté des vivants.
Quand on est juriste, surtout quand
on arrive dans un territoire,
qu'on a la liberté
et la possibilité d'observer,
C'est d'une richesse énorme,
car on se rend compte à quel point
sur notre planète, il y a des mondes
très différents qui existent.
Il s'agit de choisir à quel monde
on veut appartenir
et ce qu'on veut défendre.
J'ai fait mon choix.
-Marine, votre combat
ne date pas d'hier.
Le juriste américain
Christopher Stone défendait déjà,
dans les années 70,
des séquoias millénaires
contre Walt Disney. La firme
de Mickey souhaitait les raser
pour construire une station de ski
et un parc d'attractions.
En quoi est-ce crucial d'accorder
des droits à la nature ?
-Ce qui est fondamental
dans la pensée de Christopher Stone,
c'est qu'il nous permet de dézoomer
au niveau historique.
Il nous rappelle, dans "Les arbres
doivent-ils pouvoir plaider ?",
que l'évolution
de la personnalité juridique
est fondamentalement liée
à la culture,
à l'instant et à l'éthique
qui se trouve dans cet instant.
Il dézoome en nous rappelant
que pendant une large partie
de l'histoire de l'humanité,
les esclaves n'avaient pas
cette personnalité.
Ils étaient la propriété
de leur maître.
Il nous permet aussi
de revenir
à l'histoire des femmes,
considérées comme des incapables,
classées comme des enfants.
Même dans le régime français,
elles étaient sous la tutelle
de leur mari
ou de leur père.
Ainsi, Christopher Stone
essaie de réveiller
notre mental en disant :
"Et si donner des droits
à la nature,
"reconnaître ces droits du vivant,
"était tout simplement
le chemin éthique
"le plus normal à suivre ?"
Il l'illustre.
La personnalité et les droits
fondamentaux accordés à autrui
est une histoire, finalement,
d'accroissement concentrique.
Progressivement,
la société s'élargit
et considère les intérêts d'autrui
de manière de plus en plus large.
Aujourd'hui, Christopher Stone
nous amène à réfléchir.
Est-ce qu'élargir la focale
n'est pas nécessaire
dans la crise actuelle ?
-Et l'urgence
d'effondrement climatique.
-Oui, et lui se place
dans les années 70,
ce qui était connu, déjà.
Il parle
du réchauffement climatique,
de l'effondrement
de la biodiversité.
Si le mouvement
des droits de la nature
est en train de prendre
dans le monde,
d'Amérique du Sud
jusqu'aux Etats-Unis,
en passant par l'Ouganda et l'Inde,
c'est parce
qu'on ressent profondément
cet appel, à la fois
éthique, politique, juridique,
de s'aligner avec le fait
que les non-humains
ont forcément des droits,
et qu'il ne s'agit pas
de leur donner des droits
ou de leur conférer,
mais tout simplement
de les énoncer,
car ils ont toujours été là,
comme nos droits humains
qui ont aussi toujours été là.
En prenant du recul,
et encore une fois,
ce dézoom historique
est nécessaire,
j'en avais parlé dans mon livre,
je pense qu'il y a trois étapes
pour arriver à ce qu'une idée
s'installe pleinement
dans la société.
Quand on parlait des droits
de la nature,
les gens riaient de nous.
Ils se moquaient de l'idée
de donner des droits
à des fleuves, ou à des forêts.
L'étape numéro 2,
c'est celle de devenir un danger.
Là, on ne rigole plus.
Là, d'un coup, c'est sérieux.
On est face à des personnes
qui remettent en question
l'ordre établi.
On a un mouvement de recul,
ça devient une confrontation
entre deux ordres du monde,
justement.
Je me suis dit :
"Il faut voir plus loin."
La troisième étape
est celle qu'on souhaite atteindre.
Elle est là,
peut-être déjà atteignable,
c'est celle où l'idée
devient banale.
Il faut en passer par cette étape
du rapport de force
pour que l'idée devienne acceptée
dans notre société
et que demain,
les droits de la nature,
cette défense du vivant
soit absolument mainstream.
J'en suis convaincue, rien qu'à voir
l'éducation, aujourd'hui,
de nos enfants
qui change leur mentalité,
même dans les médias
ou dans l'opinion publique,
l'idée que nous soyons pleinement
responsables de la nature,
elle est en train de faire
un chemin très rapide
et incroyablement fulgurant.
Ce que nous, aujourd'hui,
nous avons du mal à défendre,
dans des circonstances
qui sont difficiles,
je pense que nos enfants
nous remercieront d'avoir tenu bon.
-Plus le climat se détraque,
plus les citoyens se rebiffent,
plus les procès se multiplient.
On en compte une centaine
de par le monde.
Le droit peut-il réussir
là où le politique a échoué ?
-Les deux ne peuvent pas
être déliés.
La politique est l'affaire de tous,
en théorie.
Le mouvement des droits de la nature
prend dans des territoires
où un droit souhaite être imposé
depuis le haut,
voire depuis l'extérieur.
C'est le cas
lorsque des multinationales arrivent
et imposent leur droit.
Le mouvement des droits
de la nature,
s'il prend par petites oasis,
c'est justement
parce qu'il crée un espace
dans lequel les citoyens disent :
"Nous n'acceptons plus
ce droit néocolonial,
"nous n'acceptons plus ce droit
qui ravage impunément le vivant.
"Nous voulons notre propre droit
"car nous ne voulons pas
être dans l'illégalité.
"Nous ne sommes pas des terroristes,
nous avons nos propres lois,
"qui sont respectueuses du vivant,
de notre identité,
"de nos traditions,
de notre histoire."
C'est comme ça qu'en Ouganda,
on a l'adoption d'une loi
sur les sites sacrés,
c'est comme ça qu'en Inde,
des citoyens se battent
pour les droits du Gange,
de l'Himalaya.
Ces poches de résistance
disent : "Nous avions un droit,
avant que ce droit libéral n'arrive.
"Nous avions notre droit,
qui reconnaissait
"que nous sommes interdépendants
de la nature
"et que nous sommes
responsables d'elle.
"Pour ne pas sombrer
dans l'illégalité,
"on oppose ce droit de la nature
comme étant un droit juste
"et un droit qui garantit
sur le long terme les libertés."
-Les droits accordés
à la nature,
vos adversaires craignent
les droits opposables,
c'est-à-dire une concurrence
entre les droits de la nature
qui primerait sur les droits humains
et cette crainte
va jusqu'à l'Elysée,
puisqu'Emmanuel Macron
a été le premier à craindre
que les droits de la nature viennent
contrecarrer les droits humains.
-C'est là qu'il y a
une très grande confusion.
En fait, aujourd'hui,
et c'est
jusqu'aux plus grandes instances,
comme Antonio Guterres, l'ONU,
tout le monde convient
qu'il n'y aura pas
de protection des droits humains
sans protection de la nature.
Les plus grandes
instances internationales
ont acté cela.
-C'est un faux procès ?
-Non, ce n'est pas un faux procès,
c'est délibéré.
Derrière, il y a l'idée
de faire passer le message
que protéger la nature,
c'est forcément incompatible
avec les intérêts humains.
C'est une opinion politique.
C'est une visée,
pareillement, libérale.
-Néolibérale.
C'est, finalement,
"nos libertés ou la nature.
C'est une vision politique
qu'on essaie de distiller
dans l'opinion,
comme d'autres concepts
comme l'écologie punitive,
qui servent à nourrir
cette pensée libérale.
Là, aujourd'hui, le mouvement
des droits de la nature
a cette idée qu'il faut
déconstruire cet imaginaire
et faire en sorte
que nous intégrions pleinement
que nos droits sont interdépendants
des droits de la nature.
La nature et l'homme
font partie du même système.
C'est profondément la même chose
de défendre
les droits de la nature
et les droits humains.
-L'ancienne ministre
Corinne Lepage estime néanmoins
que cette question de droits
en soulève d'autres,
d'ordre démocratique.
"Comment représenter
"ces écosystèmes,
dit-elle, et entités
"devant un tribunal,
"sans les trahir
ni les instrumentaliser ?"
Elle pose la question,
je vous la pose.
-Aujourd'hui,
beaucoup s'en plaignent,
ça passera notamment
par une reconsidération,
une revalorisation
de la pensée scientifique.
Aujourd'hui, la place laissée
à la science dans notre société,
on le voit, elle est infime.
On a de multiples instances
scientifiques,
le Conseil national de protection
de la nature,
le Haut Conseil pour le climat.
Tous sonnent l'alarme en disant :
"Nos politiques
vont dans le mauvais sens."
Comme il s'agit uniquement
d'instances consultatives,
nous n'en tenons pas compte.
Je dis "nous",
je ne m'y intègre pas.
Le gouvernement
et les lois promulguées
n'en tiennent pas compte.
Un infime pourcentage des lois
font l'objet d'un bilan carbone,
et on ne connaît pas
l'impact écologique des lois,
des programmes, des réglementations
que nous adoptons.
Il s'agit de redonner du poids
à la connaissance scientifique
pour qu'on prenne
des décisions éclairées
de ce qui est bon pour la nature
et ce qui est pérenne
sur le long terme.
Une société
qui se base sur des lois
qui sont fondamentalement
incompatibles avec le vivant
est une société qui ne peut pas
être pérenne sur le long terme.
-En 2021, le fleuve de Tavignano,
en Corse
a bénéficié d'une déclaration
de droits de la nature.
Qu'est-ce que cela signifie ?
Est-ce que cela pourrait faire
jurisprudence ?
-Il s'agit d'un mouvement
qui prend partout dans le monde.
On a une déclaration universelle
des droits des rivières,
écrite avec des juristes
et des scientifiques
du Earth Law Center.
Ce modèle, comme la déclaration
universelle des droits
de la terre-mère,
sert à répliquer des initiatives
partout dans les territoires.
On travaille sur la déclaration
pour les droits de la Seine,
sur la Garonne, en Haute-Savoie,
sur le Chéran, le Nant Bénin.
Toutes ces initiatives prennent
à partir de poches de citoyens
qui constatent,
dans leurs territoires,
l'implantation
d'une nouvelle décharge,
comme c'est le cas en Corse,
de retenues collinaires,
en Savoie,
pour le ski
et la neige artificielle,
sur la Garonne, de pollution,
de barrages ou de projets polluants.
Il y a des citoyens
qui se saisissent
de cet outil
des droits de la nature
pour faire monter ce sujet
en disant :
"Voilà les droits
que devraient avoir nos fleuves,
"nos forêts, nos rivières.
Ils contestent le système actuel
grâce à cette déclaration.
-"Les droits que devrait avoir
la nature."
Aujourd'hui, en France,
est-ce qu'un citoyen
peut engager des poursuites
contre des pollueurs au nom
d'un écosystème dégradé,
ou saisir l'Etat pour s'opposer
à un projet qu'il considèrerait
désastreux pour l'environnement ?
Est-ce possible ?
-C'est un grand problème.
En tant que citoyen isolé,
sauf si vous êtes
lésé personnellement
par un préjudice écologique,
vous ne pouvez pas agir,
ce que je trouve
anticonstitutionnel,
car notre charte de l'environnement
prévoit que chacun
doit agir
pour défendre l'environnement.
C'est, à mon sens,
quelque chose qui doit évoluer.
Dans d'autres pays,
en Equateur, en Inde,
on parle de "actio popularis".
C'est l'action ouverte à tous
de défendre l'intérêt public.
Ce n'est pas le cas en France.
A mon sens, ça doit évoluer,
pour que chacun puisse défendre
les droits de la nature.
-Pour que chacun
puisse
les défendre, l'écocide n'a pas
été reconnu dans le droit,
la convention citoyenne
l'a réclamé,
le gouvernement a tricoté la loi
pour en faire un délit de pollution.
Grosso modo, pour poursuivre l'Etat
ou une entreprise,
il faut montrer l'intentionnalité
de nuire.
-Oui.
Ce qui est très dur à comprendre
aujourd'hui,
dans ce modèle juridique,
ce qui était un vrai blocage,
c'était que l'Etat se retrouvait
à être contredit
dans son action.
On autorise aujourd'hui
énormément d'activités
qui sont fondamentalement
incompatibles
avec les besoins du vivant.
Ce qui, finalement,
était une remise en question,
l'écocide était une remise
en question de ce modèle,
les entreprises disaient :
"Comment se fait-il qu'on puisse
nous donner l'autorisation,
"et qu'ensuite,
nous contraindre par le droit ?"
Nous, nous voyons la nécessité,
aujourd'hui,
de donner la possibilité d'agir
pour écocide,
lorsque, malheureusement,
les considérations économiques,
les considérations
strictement financières
ont justifié certaines activités.
Il faut donner la possibilité
aux juges d'agir
lorsque les droits du vivant
ne peuvent pas être garantis
sur le long terme.
On a fait un modèle,
malheureusement,
une proposition de l'écocide
qui a fait peur,
qui a fait peur.
En même temps,
elle a ouvert un débat.
Il faut se projeter
sur le long terme.
-"L'écocide, écrit Dominique Bourg,
"n'est pas le crime ultime
mais le crime premier, le crime
"transcendantal, qui réunira
"les conditions d'habilité
de la Terre."
Ce crime, aujourd'hui,
Marine Calmet,
n'est toujours pas reconnu.
Les entreprises ont-elles
un devoir de vigilance ?
-Oui, évidemment.
On l'applique très mal,
car on voit à quel point le juge
a du mal à se saisir de cet outil.
Plusieurs procès
sont en cours,
on n'a pas
de grande jurisprudence...
-Il y a un délit d'imprudence ?
-Oui.
On le connaît parfaitement.
Dans le domaine social,
lorsque vous ne protégez pas
vos salariés,
un chef d'entreprise
peut être condamné
pour les avoir mis en danger.
-La criminalité environnementale
est en hause :
+ 7 % entre 2016 et 2021,
mais il y a peu de risques
d'être contrôlé,
faute de personnel formé,
et les sanctions
sont relativement faibles.
La réponse pénale
n'est pas dissuasive, en France.
-Oui, ce n'est pas nouveau.
Ca vient d'une culture
assez profonde.
Quand on est allés rencontrer
notre ministre de la Justice,
celui-ci a dit, face aux citoyens,
face à moi-même :
"Il n'y a pas de crime
contre l'environnement."
-Eric Dupond-Moretti ?
-Oui.
En fait, pour lui,
il n'y a que des délits
contre la nature.
On ne peut pas commettre
de crime contre l'environnement.
Pourtant, si.
On le voit, des crimes majeurs
sont commis contre la nature
chaque jour.
Ca vient profondément d'un oubli,
d'un impensé, parce que nous sommes
dominants sur la nature.
Pour ça, encore, j'aime utiliser
un comparatif historique.
J'avais une discussion
avec ma belle-mère,
qui s'est battue
pour le droit des femmes.
Elle me disait :
"Ce que tu portes avec l'écocide,
"ça me fait penser à nos débats
pour la criminalisation du viol",
parce qu'on considère trop souvent
que violer une femme est un délit,
parce que les hommes disposent
du corps des femmes
et que s'ils prennent, c'est bien
que ces femmes étaient disponibles.
"Elles étaient au mauvais endroit
au mauvais moment,
"mal habillées,
ou en mauvaise compagnie.
"C'est la faute des femmes,
"ce qui leur arrive."
Pour la nature, c'est pareil.
On considère que prendre
le corps de la nature, en disposer,
c'est le droit des hommes.
-Aujourd'hui, votre combat,
c'est de faire reconnaître
le crime d'écocide ?
-C'est un changement culturel
profond,
parce que c'est tout simplement
reconnaître
que notre relation à la nature
a malheureusement un côté criminel,
lorsqu'on est incapable de voir
ce qu'on cause.
Pour toute personne
qui est descendue dans une mine,
comme je l'ai fait,
qui a constaté
la destruction massive
des entrailles de la terre
par les êtres humains,
les machines qu'on a inventées
pour littéralement vider la terre
de sa substance,
on se rend compte à quel point
la domination et la violence
marquent notre relation
à la Terre.
-Quand un industriel est condamné
pour avoir pollué une rivière,
qui reçoit les dédommagements,
les indemnités ?
L'Etat, qui subventionne
les énergies fossiles,
ou les associations qui se battent
et peinent à rembourser
leurs frais d'avocats ?
Où va cet argent ?
-Souvent, oui,
les condamnations vont à l'Etat.
Les associations, heureusement,
peuvent bénéficier,
dans certains cas,
du remboursement de certains frais.
En fait, il faut voir, aujourd'hui,
qu'il y a énormément de citoyens
qui, par leur implication,
par leur temps
et par leur argent,
aident des associations qui font
un travail d'intérêt public.
Aujourd'hui, c'est ce qui est
très compliqué, je trouve,
dans notre manière d'agir,
et qui est un frein monumental,
c'est le financement
des associations.
J'ai travaillé, je travaille
avec des associations
qui font un travail extraordinaire.
S'il n'y avait pas les associations
pour protéger l'environnement,
la situation
serait gravissime.
Je n'ose pas imaginer
le visage
de la France si, en Guyane,
il n'y avait pas eu ces collectifs
qui, tous les jours, font ce travail
pour protéger la forêt et la terre.
Partout en France,
tous ces collectifs
qui alertent
sur la pollution de l'eau
ou sur la destruction des forêts.
C'est impressionnant.
-La France a été condamnée
trois fois pour inaction climatique,
sans que ces condamnations
ne changent les choses.
Vers qui ou vers quoi se tourner ?
-Il y a une expression
que j'utilise souvent,
c'est de dire que le juge
est l'homme du passé.
Le juge ne peut pas
contraindre l'Etat
à prendre des décisions,
parce qu'on a la séparation
des pouvoirs
qui fait que c'est le pouvoir
exécutif qui exécute,
qui met en place des politiques.
Le juge constate des effractions.
C'est arrivé dans le cas
des carences fautives
en matière de lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique.
Le juge constate
l'inaction de l'Etat,
mais en fait, la solution,
elle est à l'intérieur
de chacun de nous.
On ne peut pas attendre du juge
de faire ce travail
à la place des gouvernants.
On ne peut pas non plus,
en tant que citoyen,
attendre du gouvernant qu'il fasse
le travail si, objectivement,
tous les indices nous disent :
"Ce gouvernement
ne va pas le faire."
Aujourd'hui,
au lieu d'investir massivement
dans la protection
des droits de la nature,
on investit des centaines
de millions d'euros
pour développer des carburants
pour faire voler des avions verts.
C'est ça, le problème.
Construire un imaginaire,
ça demande aussi
que chacun d'entre nous s'y mette.
Aujourd'hui, on a besoin, vraiment,
d'un mouvement citoyen
qui se mette en place et qui change
profondément la société.
Ca ne va pas venir du haut.
Ca va venir de nous.
Avec l'association Wild Legal,
on essaye vraiment
d'accompagner les territoires
qui souhaitent utiliser
les droits de la nature.
Ca ne viendra pas d'une grande loi,
d'une nouvelle constitution,
pas maintenant, c'est clair.
Vu le modèle actuel, c'est trop tôt.
Ce qu'on voit,
en travaillant localement,
c'est des gestionnaires
de parcs naturels,
des citoyens, des élus,
des présidents,
des directeurs de parcs,
de syndicats de gestion des eaux,
qui font ce travail au quotidien
et qui constatent
le droit de l'environnement
d'aujourd'hui.
Ca ne suffira pas.
Il faut
des gouvernances biomimétiques,
il nous faut un droit
qui soit respectueux
des fonctionnalités du vivant
et qui se dise : "Comment faire ?"
On peut accompagner
ces transitions,
car localement,
on a des petits pouvoirs.
On a aussi la possibilité
de planifier,
de créer
des gouvernances différentes.
Ca demande juste
de la volonté, de la créativité.
On le fait au quotidien.
-Merci.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA